stellen sie sich vor bei ihnen klingelt
das telefon und die polizei bestellt sie
aufs revier
dort sehen sie dann das video von einer
vergewaltigung das opfer das sind sie ja
so ist es edith steht fest der frau von
gute zeiten schlechte zeiten
schauspieler eric steht fest passiert
heute heute musste sie ihren peiniger
vor gericht wiedersehen
der tatvorwurf ist erschreckend mit
drogen bezeugt liegt steht fest laut
aussage regungslos auf dem boden
dann soll der heute 35 jährige max hat
die damals 17-jährige hilflose frau erst
ausgezogen und dann vergewaltigt haben
der angeklagte habe die tat sogar
gefilmt laut staatsanwaltschaft muss max
h gewusst haben dass erde betäubt war
und somit nicht im stande war sich zu
wehren
bevor die aufnahmen vor zwei jahren
aufgetaucht sind soll jetzt steht fest
gar nichts von ihrer vergewaltigung
gewusst haben ja vor zwei jahren den
anruf bekommen auf mein handy vom lka
berlin mit der aussage ich sollte aufs
revier kommen ich solle ein opfer
identifizieren ich bin dorthin gesagt
und dachte es geht um irgendjemanden
anderen und wurde dort in einen raum
gebracht und musste mir die aufnahme
einer vergewaltigung ansehen und habe
dann erst in diesem raum gesehen dass
ich das bin
möglicher gedächtnisverlust durch ko
tropfen ich habe den angeklagten in
leipzig kennen gelernt als ich 17 war im
zuge von im druck weil als 17-jährige
war es nicht leicht überhaupt jemanden
zu finden der einem minderjährigen toben
gibt und er war eben der einzige dealer
der dafür gesorgt hat dass ich zu dem
komme und höchstwahrscheinlich diese
machtposition auch bewusst genutzt hat
im saal selber war ich total froh dass
er nicht mir gegenüber saß sondern dass
der an der seite saß und das sich nur
zwei mal kurz in die augen schauen
musste und eric saß durfte mit drin
bleiben im saal und hat eigentlich die
ganze zeit dafür gesorgt dass immer wenn
der täter mich anschaut hat ihr ich ihn
so intensiv angeschaut hat dass er sich
wieder versteckt hat und versucht hat zu
verhöhnen
das hat mir die kraft gegeben nicht so
angestarrt zu werden
dem mutmasslichen täter wird zudem die
verbreitung kinderpornografischer
aufnahme in elf fällen vorgeworfen
die kinder sollen unter 14 jahre alt
gewesen sein hochschwanger muss die
sängerin nun gegen ihren mutmaßlichen
vergewaltiger wegen des missbrauchs
widerstandsunfähiger personen vor dem
leipziger amtsgericht aussagen in
begleitung ihres mannes dem gzsz
schauspieler erich steht fest er drei
jahre und vier monate hat der täter
dafür bekommen ein urteil das edith
steht fest schwer nachvollziehen konnte
sie hatte heute nicht mehr die kraft mit
uns darüber zu sprechen jedoch ihr mann
erich jetzt nach dem urteil
deswegen redet kann jetzt gerade nicht
mehr damit hier dabei sein
war es für sie glaube ich jetzt einfach
sehr sehr schwierig dass er erst mal
wieder nach hause gehen kann
obwohl er eine haftstrafe bekommen hat
hat jetzt zeit berufung einzulegen
ja genau das war jetzt einfach noch mal
sehr intensiv einfach auch weil die
richterin sehr eindrücklich beschrieben
hat wie schlimm das ganze war und es
also nicht hat es gerade auch noch mal
richtig richtig mitgenommen
das noch mal so zu hören
also ich glaube dass ich als person ganz
wichtig war für redet in diesem prozess
und ich das irgendwie tragen kann und
ich frage mich halt ob nicht vielmehr
frauen noch das los werden könnten wenn
sie jemanden mit dabei hätten der
unabhängig von anwälten usw
da vielleicht mit anwesend ist ja
unglaublich
der prozess musste immer wieder
verschoben werden weil der täter auf
drogen im gerichtssaal immer wieder fast
einschläft heute daneben das urteil drei
jahre und vier monate
was bedeutet dieses urteil für eric und
veredelt steht fest darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit unserem chef michael herz der
bei uns hier im studio ist halo hauke du
kennst die beiden du kennst
dieses paar wir haben die das urteil
aufgenommen was bedeutet dieses urteil
jetzt für die beiden für die werden ist
es erstmal eine wahnsinnige entlastung
man muss sich vorstellen zwei jahre
konnten die darüber nicht reden mussten
das für sich behalten
in diesen zwei jahren hat sich für die
beiden unendlich viel verändert geben
sich aus der öffentlichkeit
zurückgezogen sind aus berlin die am bei
mir in berlin um die ecke gelebt ich
habe immer auch in den zwei jahren immer
mit denen auch geredet ich habe lange
zeit auch von der ganzen sache nichts
gewusst und für die geht jetzt einfach
ein wahnsinniger druck zu ende weil sie
darüber nie sprechen konnten und ich
meine man muss sich das vorstellen was
die beiden da erlebt haben vor zwei
jahren kommt ein anruf edith steht fest
wer zur polizei bekommt ein video
gezeigt was unglaublich brutal
unglaublich eine vergewaltigung zeigt
das muss das paar erstmal verkraften und
für die beiden geht jetzt an die lange
zeit erstmal zu ende
und jetzt müssen sie natürlich erstmal
sehen wie geht es für sie weiter weiter
wie wird das weiter ihr leben sollten
wie soll das auch ihr leben weiter
bestimmen das müssen die beiden jetzt
erst mal für sich auch erstmal finden ja
welche rolle hat erik steht fest dort
als stütze für seine frau gespielt du
kennst ihn ja wie konnte er sie in
dieser schwierigen zeit auf wandel ja
das hat er ich bin durch beeindruckt von
dem wir die das hinbekommen haben
man hat das ja gesehen er ist immer bei
an ihrer seite gewesen die beiden haben
hände gehalten edel sind auch in den
letzten zwei tagen nach denen das ganze
ja auch für sie noch mal alles neu
erlebt worden ist im gerichtssaal war
sie abends auch wirklich emotional
erledigt und es ist ganz klar dirk ist
einfach ein wahnsinnig wichtige stütze
für sie die vorgeschichte der beiden
beide waren ja drogenabhängig und eric
hat damals auch edith geholfen clean zu
werden das heißt jetzt war er wieder
eine ganz wichtige stütze für sie und
die beiden sind als paar wie ich das
jetzt beobachte habe aber auch
unglaublich daran gewachsen und noch mal
haben sie auch gesagt ja auch kann noch
mal den beitrag unheimlich wieder fest
zusammengewachsen dazu kommt ja auch
noch jede des hochschwanger also was für
eine belastung in so ein prozess zu
gehen bei so einem fall der uns so schon
völlig ausreicht für ein ganzes leben
und sie erlebten auch noch hochschwanger
was findet belaste absolut also
körperlich eine wahnsinnige belastung im
januar soll das kind kommen an der
tochter und dass ich meine die der
prozess ist jetzt eben diese phase
gefallen sie haben sich im letzten jahr
bewusst entschieden noch ein kind zu
bekommen ich glaube das war für diese
beziehung der beiden auch ein wichtiges
signal
sie haben ja schon einen sohn der es
vier jahre den haben sie bekommen als
beide clean waren das war für sie beide
ein staat eigentlich dass sie gesagt
habe okay wir wollen früh kinder haben
wir wollen kinder haben wir sind beide
klien wir machen das und wollen ein kind
haben und ich glaube dass diese
entscheidung für das kind ganz bewusst
wahr aber es war körperlich vergeht eine
wahnsinnige belastungen sieht ja mit was
für ein bock sie dann gerichtssaal sitzt
und der geburtstermin ist ja auch jetzt
nicht mehr weit hin aber sie hat das gut
überstanden soweit ich das sehe es ist
alles gut soweit alles in ordnung für
sie und ich hoffe jetzt dass sie dann
frohe gute nachrichten sind willkommen
zurück in die familie
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren